i think that um
[Music]
you know in some ways coming off of
um a reality tv show for anybody
is a challenging journey i wanted to
prove that
i'm a person um that has more to offer
than just um drama on a television show
let's talk about love wellness but also
let's talk about creating cultivate
because you are just part of the digital
self-care and beauty summit
why was that a good vehicle for you to
sort of use to talk about your company
absolutely um i've always been a big fan
of creighton cultivate and
it's always been a really great platform
to connect with other entrepreneurs
founders but also the audience the
people that are interested in crete and
cultivate come there for a reason to
educate themselves on different topics
and i always get an amazing education
from other people that i sit on panels
with and so for me
it's just as much a learning and growing
experience
as it is uh for me to you know share my
personal story
well let's talk love wellness because
this has been your baby your company
since 2006. yes
okay so what is the mission and what
really inspired this
yeah so it's been four years now um
for people watching that don't know i'm
the founder and ceo of love wellness
we make clean body positive personal
care products for women
and i started the company back in 2016
because i personally was not well
i was suffering from a bunch of vitamin
deficiencies
and at that point in time nobody was
really talking about that
but it really was affecting my health
top to bottom
inside and out depression anxiety all
kinds of things
and as a result of that i was at the
drugstore a lot and i was taking a lot
of prescriptions
and i really felt like what was
available for women at the time
was just not cutting it from a marketing
perspective
from a messaging perspective packaging
and then the formulation and ingredients
really were not cutting it and so i
worked with my doctors
to kind of create my own path to
get better and it's when i started using
products
that were more naturally formulated with
clean ingredients
that i actually did get better and i
thought hmm there's an opportunity here
to do something really meaningful for
women
what are some of the biggest women's
issues that you feel
like aren't talked about enough and
and what can we do to get that
conversation more out there
absolutely i think that there is
a huge disconnect between
products that are out there and
available for women and how they
actually
work with the body i think right now
we're seeing
a lot of conversations around fertility
pregnancy menopause gut health
and then we have a lot of younger women
who are on the platform that are curious
about
puberty and their periods and is my body
normal
and to be able to provide a safe space
where we can have those conversations
with that
expert advice i think makes a world of
difference
we actually have created a safe and
legitimate platform for women to
express themselves and get help so much
of what you're doing
stems from your own personal experience
it seems like was there a moment
like a really hard moment a rock bottom
where you were like i need
change yeah i think for me it was
when i was really struggling with my
health a few years ago
i was living in new york city i was
almost 30
and i was still trying to figure out
my path forward in a career sense
and also just with my personal life i
had gone to culinary school and i was
creating a lot of wellness content
already and a lot of food content
how to focus on farm to table so i was
really educating myself
about food and sourcing and nutrition
and so i was
learning about all of these things and
i felt illuminated and i felt like other
people
deserved to have the experience that i
was
going through at the time which was
having those
aha moments of self-discovery when it
comes to
how you feel about the world about your
body and how to really be
well and so i would say truly it was
you know when i was visiting two
different doctors a week just to figure
out what was wrong with me
that i really started to ideate the
concept of love wellness
and became more excited to bring it to
life
do you feel like all of your years in
the public eye and on reality tv
at all contributed to your
struggles with anxiety or depression at
all i think that
if you are a public figure to a certain
degree
you have to figure out how you feel
about that more than anything else
and i was cast onto television when i
was
in high school i believe it was our
junior year and we filmed that first
season of lacuna our senior year
and i was 17 when i went to school and
the first episode premiered and i had to
figure out pretty quickly how i felt
about
um my new role within this
public-facing universe and frankly it
made me
uncomfortable but once you open
pandora's box
you can't close it again there's no
going back
and so from that point forward it was
me as a young person figuring out how to
deal with um
deal with what i was dealing with and
it was challenging for me certainly i
think other people really love
the limelight and you know love to be on
social media and love to put their lives
out there
for me i'm a much more private person
and i really love having a normal job
and
going to work every day i had to really
figure out how to deal with
people knowing who i am saying things
about me
uninformed opinions right because when
you see somebody out in the world it's
always just a snapshot of their life
it's never the full picture and
so it can be really challenging to try
to constantly stick up for yourself and
so you have to
um be resolute in who you are and
confident in who you are
and thankfully over the past 10 years
i've been able
to do that really effectively and i
think in a lot of ways it's why
i'm an effective leader at love wellness
because we're talking about things that
are not the most comfortable but for me
i learned the lesson a long time ago
that i can have an outspoken voice and
be okay with that
and it has led us to create an entirely
new category of amazing products for
women
you said that you this is more your lane
having this
job that you have now kind of being away
from the spotlight
um but i think that i read that you felt
pressure by people to get
a real job at one point so
now that you do have this company what
do you say to those people
you know in in some ways coming off of
um a reality tv show for anybody
is a challenging journey i think that
you have opportunities to continue
to pursue a career in entertainment if
that suits you
or you can go back to a more
private life but then you still have to
deal with people knowing who you are
and so i think for me i always wanted to
prove
myself and i wanted to prove that
i'm a person that has more to offer
than just um drama on a television show
i'm smart i have a perspective i have a
voice i have a platform
and i can use it for positive change for
women
and so i'm elated to be able to do that
did being on television make it harder
to find a normal job or easier because
you were able to forge your own
company absolutely easier because i was
really able to forge my own path
there's so many benefits that i have
personally experienced as a result
of being on tv so i'm really grateful
for the experience
yeah there's just a lot of personal
emotions that you have to work through
if you are put into a situation like
that but for me
absolutely i do have to ask you about
the hills
of course yeah did you watch season one
of new beginnings
i didn't no are you kind of so
over that part of your life
i think it's um interesting and fun at
this point
you know um i'm not sure
if i would ever participate in anything
like that again i have
really created my own path
um that i'm just so happy to be on
and i think i'm getting close to
having succeeded in building the life
that i've always dreamed for myself
you know yeah it's funny because i've
talked to both kristen
and warren about the hills in the past
couple of months and kristen is making a
cameo
in season two would you ever just make a
cameo
no not no oh yeah i'm really
i'm so happy with where i'm at um i
think i'm the only person that lives
in new york uh i live all the way across
the country
and i'm really focused on where i'm
at in my life right now i think when you
sign up um
to participate in something like that at
this point you really know what you're
getting into
when we first started we had no idea
right because the shows that we were on
sort of created a new category of
television programming
so we have known um but now
you are fully aware of what you are
getting yourself into
and signing up for and frankly i don't
want paparazzi to be standing outside my
building waiting for me
it that's not a life that i choose for
myself
um you know i'm in control of my own
narrative at this point
and it's the happiest that i've ever
been yeah
are you still friends with lauren we're
friends we're well everybody's still
friends
everyone's still your friends like do
you text for the people still
sometimes yeah i've lived in new york
for
eight years um and so absolutely
relationships change over time but still
friendly with everybody
i know you don't want paparazzi but
would you ever do reality tv if it was
something different or if it was even
about your company
at this point no no we've seen such
incredible growth and success with what
we're doing
without inviting in cameras
or scrutiny or a director's perspective
on how they think things should be
presented to the world
there's a lot of power in not being on
reality television
because you're able to control your own
narrative
speaking of controlling your own
narrative and you sort of touched on
this
earlier but you are very private on your
instagram like you don't show much of
your personal life
it's is that intentional like are you
dating in quarantine right now
i have an interesting relationship with
instagram sort of the same kind of
relationship that people do with their
bank accounts where they don't really
want to log in and see
listen
i'm not i'm not intentionally not
sharing
i just frankly don't think that what i'm
doing
is like so spectacular that it needs to
be
put out there yeah and the love wellness
instagram account
does most of my work for me at this
point okay
that's really you know the message and
the story that i want to get behind
um and so you can see a lot of myself
there through the messaging and through
what we're trying to do as a brand
will you ever show the personal aspect
of yourself on your own
instagram like if there's a special
person
yeah i'm sure at some point and like i
do
here and there you know what i mean but
it's just not my focus
to be honest with you what does the next
five years look like for you
both professionally and personally for
me i'm really excited to continue
to grow love wellness as a brand
to continue to create new products and i
would love to
have a home in california and spend more
time with my family
and and that's it i think it's been a
really interesting year
so far and so there's so many question
marks on the future
and i've just gotten way more
comfortable with taking it day by day